à qui je m'en allais bon je laisse ça va
casimir ne manque pas trop
oh bien sûr que si quand il n'est pas
dans le jardin l'île aux enfants n'est
pas tout à fait la même
mais enfin aujourd'hui il est absent
juste pour la journée de toute façon il
était tellement content d'avoir une
aussi grande responsabilité
c'est vrai si la première fois qu'il
fait quelque chose d'aussi important ça
le le gardien du parc d'animaux étaient
vraiment gentil lui confier la garde des
animaux pour la journée tu sais qu'il
est très content d'avoir trouvé
quelqu'un pour le remplacer aujourd'hui
que je suis sûr que casimir est un
excellent gardien
tu as tout à fait raison julie faut pas
s'inquiéter les animaux sont tellement
heureux dans l'île aux enfants
casimir n'aura pratiquement rien à faire
pour les enfants volés bonjour julie et
un salut françois bon jour mais cette
campagne aux facteurs quel bon ben vous
amène du courrier pour moi allons n'ont
pas aujourd'hui c'est même presque ce
qu'on pourrait appeler une visite à
titre privé je voulais être le premier à
vous annoncer la la pomme nouvelle
recette est
raconter nice a dit à poursuit on vous a
les actions posées on ne nous fait pas
languir facteurs mais quelle est cette
grande nouvelle figurez vous que je
rencontre monsieur du snob nous
échangeons quelques mots quand tout à
coup je vois que ses yeux kikicé karting
alors je suis dans la direction de son
regard
et devinez ce que je vois j'en ai pas la
moindre idée
je donne ma langue au chat à eybens je
vois un énorme cargo qui entre dans le
corps
super majestueux et oui c'était le quasi
les russes premier qui rentrait avec
deux jours d'avancé un mais oui il est
parti déjà il ya deux semaines crée oui
pour apporter certaines espèces animales
inconnu dans l'île aux enfants aux mets
en avait plein surtout le pont j'ai vu
d'elle et des léopards des ours blancs
des perroquets des amis les animaux de
toutes sortes
ça devait exploser ou scandent-ils
magnifique dit mais alors c'était la
vraie fête
yaya revue tous les bateaux qui
actionnait la leurs sirènes ça faisait
les gens sortaient de chez eux pour
aller sur le quai les animaux à les
animaux les animaux étaient tous en
parfaite santé
seulement certains étaient c'est un peu
fatigué par le voyage
alors on les a tout de suite dirigés
vers le parc des animaux ou le gardien
doit être en train de s'en occuper bien
entendu mais françois le gardien
aujourd'hui c'est oui oui mais c'est
quasi mis au fond me fait une blague là
mais pas du tout facteur le gardien du
parc d'animaux a justement choisi
aujourd'hui pour s'absenter
il a confié la garde des animaux a
quasiment en europe
je me demandais comment il va se
débrouiller au mes amis mes amis venez
vite j'ai besoin de votre aide
il arrive un malheur les émirs certains
animaux se sont-ils sauver non non mais
il en est arrivé plein de nouveau
aujourd'hui trouvé ça nous savons oui le
facteur nous a mis au courant oui mais
moi mon problème c'est comme je ne sais
pas ce qu'ils préfèrent un show et ceux
qui préfèrent le froid casimir du
connais leur espèce
ah oui j'ai toute une liste rares
gargiulo démarquer oui et bien coûte
nous allons demander aux enfants ils te
donneront sûrement les bonnes réponses
je compte sur vous un c'est une bonne
idée françois alors les enfants
voilà ce qui se passe casimir en place
aujourd'hui le gardien du parc d'animaux
il ne tenait pas les animaux qui
préfèrent la chaleur et les animaux qui
préfèrent le froid voulait bien l'aider
oui
et vous serez kazimiyah alors casimir
les enfants on commence un phoque
alors il aime le froid et le chaud dans
un pays froid je parle notre ca les
ventes dans les pays froids un sénèque
c'est un renard des sables fenech en sa
une le show le sort le show le che sur
un chameau un chameau le show et lyon a
lyon je jouis sauvé lyon 1 mars un morse
le froid une otarie froid un titre le
show un téléphone chaud j'espère que
chez eux nous et ce avec quoi répondent
avec vous à un pingouin le froid piquant
dit le show mais c'est le froid
un ours blanc le froid 1 rennes
non c'est pas les chaînes céline a
raison avesnes le froid dans les pays
froids le show un crocodile un crocodile
de chaud par le froid chercher chez vous
une panthère il sur gazon
vous êtes une panthère le show un chien
slymo le froid excuse moi les sh eskimos
très bien qu'ils tirent les traîneaux
dans une lettre d'accord me froid un
zèbre un zèbre le show n'offrons pas
aidé par le shu elle ou non c'est le
froid enfin il ya certains loups mais
très très très très très peu qui vivent
dans les régions tempérées
mais la plupart des nous aiment le froid
un caribou
qu'est ce que ça vous le froid très bien
flamants roses
le show est bien casimir oui j'ai tout
passé en revue voilà tu sais tout et
bien tu vas en avoir du travail pour sûr
ce ne sera pas facile à faire mais
facteurs oui je voudrais vous demander
un petit service est ce que vous ne
pourriez pas me remplacer je ne me sens
pas très bien aux hommes
j'essaie un peu de faire plaisir oui tu
es malade kazimi non non je dis ce n'est
pas très grave juste un petit rhume avec
toutes ces questions je crois bien que
j'ai attrapé un show et l'effroi
que j'aimais